على كل من القاهره ينضم الينا كل من استاذ
الشريعه الاسلاميه بجامعه الازهر الدكتور
احمد كريمه والمحاميه والخبيره في شؤون
المراه اشجان البخاري اهلا بكما دكتور
احمد يسعد صباحك شكرا عن تواجدك معنا على
اي اساس قلتم انهم لا مانعه من طلب البنت
يد الشاب للزواج
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم اولا لا مانع حيث
لا مانع
لان في وقائع في التاريخ الاسلامي
يعني مثلا السيده خديجه بنت خويلد رضي
الله عنها وارضاها
لما بلغها الامانه والصدق
والاخلاق الكريمه في سيدنا النبي محمد صلى
الله عليه وسلم لما تاجر بمالها في الشام
توسطت صديقه مقربه للسيده خديجه رضي الله
عنها
وعرضت على النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ان
يتزوج من ذات حسب ونسب ومال
هذه واقعه معروفه في السيره النبويه
ايضا في الحديث في الاحاديث النبويه
جاءت امراه الى مسجد النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم في المدينه النبويه المنوره
وقالت هذه المسلمه
وابت لك نفسي يا رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم
فاطرقا حياء وتواضعا واعراضا او اعتذارا
يعني
فقال رجل من الجالسين
ان لم يكن بك حاجه يعني في الزواج
منها يا رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
فزوجني اياها
قال ما يعني من مهر قال لا شيء
اسمع منك يا شيخ احمد
احمد كيف بدها البنت
تطلع بجانب رجل لم يحسم امره في مساله
الزواج يعني حتى في هذه المساله من الاساس
مش هو اللي بده يطلب ايدها ويكون رجل على
قد المسؤوليه ويدير بيت ويدير امور الحياه
الزوجيه
يا سيده نحن لم نقل يجب
ليس واجبا وليس حراما وليس مكروها هو يباع
للمراه سواء كانت بكرا او سيبا
ان تبدي الموافقه او الايجاب والقبول
بالنسبه
للكفؤ او الصالح او لمن تثق به فلا مانع
حيث لا مانع لان لما نقول حرام يبقى عندنا
يكون صيغه ده لما نقول مكروه صيغه ناهي
الامر الاخر
الاسلام للعرب ولغير العرب اذا كان العرف
عند العرب ان ده مستنكر
لكن الاسلام رساله عالميه للعرب ولغير
العرب فاذا استنكر في المنطقه العربيه
لا يستنكر
في ماليزيا في
اندونيسيا في اوروبا في امريكا لان
الاسلام رسالته عالميا
ولو تركتني بس اكمل الحديث ان المراه لما
عرضت نفسها في المسجد
قال رجل من الصحابه رضي الله عنهم وارضاهم
زوجني اياها ان لم يكن بك حاجه
قال التمس ولو خاتما من حديد قال لا اجب
قال ان تحفظ شيئا من القران الكريم قال
نعم سوره كذا وصوره كذا
فتم الزواج في القران الكريم حصل مع سيدنا
موسى عليه السلام ان العبد الصالح عرض على
سيدنا موسى المصاهره اني اريد ان انكحك
احدى ابنتين هاتين على ان تاجرني ثمان حجج
فان اتممت عشرا فمن عندك واقام
تحميه اللي هو سيدنا موسى عليه السلام مده
من الزمن قبل ان يتوجه الى مصر مرورا
بسيناء
وجهه نظرك الكلمه لك الان لكي نسمع وجهه
نظر الاخرى فيما يتعلق بهذا الخصوص
صباح الخير وسعيده اننا معكم
بدات يا فندم العادات والتقاليد والعرف
المجتمعي وردود افعال الناس بترفض ذلك
تماما فانا باعتباري محاميه وعندي مكتب
وعندي طبقات مختلفه من المواطنين في
المكتب بمجرد ما عرفت بموضوع الحلقه
بالامس فحبيت اعمل استطلاع راي لنفسي انا
عشان اشوف ايه يعني يعني ايه الطرح الجديد
اللي طالع لنا به مولانا احمد الشيخ احمد
كريمه
فلقيت رفض تام جدا من من الاباء ومن
الامهات ومن البنات نفسهم لان هم يعني مش
حضرتك مش متخيل يعني ايه بنت تروح تتقدم
لولد وينظر اليها النظره الدونيه لما
البنت تتقدم لولد
للاسف ده هيقلل من حقوقها ومن طلباتها
من
المزايا اللي المفروض يعني البنت تطلب ولا
ولا تطلب البنت تطلب ولا تطلب حياء كرامه
عزه نفس
قيمه
الفتاه العربيه او المسلمه او العربيه
عامه واحنا واحنا في مجتمع الشرقي يرفض
ذلك تماما يا يا مولانا يعني انا معرفش
حضرتك الطرح ده انت جايبه قلت سيدنا محمد
والسيده خديجه
رحمه الله عليها وسيدنا محمد عليه الصلاه
والسلام لا يقارن شاب اليوم علشان الواحده
تامن على نفسها معاه زي سيدنا محمد ولا
تقارن سيده كريمه بالسيده خديجه فما ينفع
فده قياس كان اصلا مش للزواج ليس الهدف
منه الزواج وانما كان زواج السيده خديجه
وتوسط السيده كمان يعني متوسطه السيده ولم
تطلب السيده خديجه بذات نفسها يد الرسول
عليه الصلاه والسلام وانما وسطت حياء
وكرامه ونصره للدين الاسلامي لانها ارادت
ان تنصره وان تقوي منه وان تساعده على نشر
الدين الاسلامي في هذا التوقيت وانتم اعلم
منا بامور الدين الاسلامي يا مولانا الشيخ
احمد ولكن احنا بنتكلم في مجتمع النهارده
احنا في سنه 23 20 23
المراه او الفتاه الدكتور لا تقبل على
نفسها هذا ابدا الدكتور احمد ما قال يجوز
فقط في هذه الحاله تشرحي لنا كيف ليس من
صالح المراه
اولا هو قال يجوز واحنا عارفين ان هو يجوز
بس
ازاي بنت هتقلل من قيمه نفسها ومن
كبريائها وعزه نفسها اللي هي بتبقى مستنيه
العريس يخبط على الباب ويقولوا له اتفضل
انا عايز اخطب بنتكم طلباتكم ايه لكن انا
لما اروح كفتاه علشان اتقدم للشاب الشاب
والعقول الطلباتي ايه يبقى انت هنا حضرتك
بطريق غير مباشر بتهين المراه المصريه او
الفتاه المصريه لان هنا بتقلل من شانها
لانها يجب ان تعزز وان تكرم وان تباهي
عائلاتها بنفسها
وبكرامتها وعزه نفسها بان الباب
يطرق لطرابها البنت تطلب ولا تطلق ولا
تطلب البنت يقبل عليها ولا تقبل على شاب
لان هذا يقال لما انا بيجيني شاب بقول له
انا عايزه مهري كذا وعايزه كذا ومؤخري كذا
لكن من انا لما اروح الكلام ده كله مش
هتقدر تعمل نفسيها
شيخ احمد
ما تيجي البنت كمان وتدفع الشاب كل فلوس
الزواج وتدفع له كمان حاجه مثل المهر اذا
هي اذا هيك صارت الموضوع
حاجات حاجات يا استاذه حاجات لا ليس الامر
كما يعني تبادر اليكم خلينا في الواقع
العملي اليست هناك علاقات بريئه احنا نحسن
الظن بالناس
ما بيحصل علاقات في محيط الدراسه في
الجامعه في محيط الوظائف
وبيتم اتفاق ما بين الفتاوى بين الشاب قبل
ان يذهب الى منزل اسرتها يعني احنا وانا
اكرر احنا لم نقل يجب
قلنا يجوز الامر الاخر اذا كان العرب
يتاففون من ذلك الاسلام ليس للعرب فقط
يعني في مجتمعات
الان المراه لها كرامتها ولها حريتها
وتعبر عن ذاتها نفرض ان امراه اعجبت
باخلاق رجل الكفر ووثقت به وقالت يشرفني
ان ارتبط به ما المانع ما المانع
بين المراه والرجل شيخ احمد
العرف الفاسد اذا واجه النص الشرعي لا
يعمل به انا قلت الحديث واضح يعني بعد
واقعه السيده خديجه عليه رضوان الله
المراه جاءت بقدميها لمسجد النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم وقالت وهبت لك نفسي يا رسول
الله على مسمع وامراه
وانتهى الامر بان احد الصحابه تزوجها في
المسجد يعني كان مجلس العبد في المسجد
فالمانع في هذا الجعان كلمه
القياس مع الفريق الشديد يا مولانا القياس
مع الفارق الشديد ما ينفعش تقول الرسول
جاءت له واحده المسجد تقول له انا عايزه
قلبها بنفسي لك يعني معنى كده انك انت
بتشجع البنات الصغيره اللي تسمعك تروح
تقول للشباب كده وينتشر بقى زيجات ومسميات
وحاجات ما فيهاش ضمان لحقوق الفتاه لا ما
ينفعش
ارجو ان نفهم الامور عليه الصلاه والسلام
ولا احد يقارن بالسيده خديجه رضوان الله
عليها لا احنا في 23 حضرتك قلت علاقات
علاقات لكن مش البنت تروح تهب نفسها وتقدم
نفسها وهبه
وتقول له انا عايزه اتجوزك وانا عايزه
اجيلك واخطبك لا العلاقات يعني قبل ما
بتبدا
الجامعه او في العمل بيبقى الشاب او الرجل
هو اللي طلب البنت طيب استاذ اشجان
المعطيات الدينيه التي استند اليها
الدكتور احمد كانت واضحه انت تقولين انه
احنا في عام 2023
للمساواه والبعض يعتبر انه هذا جزء من
المساواه خصوصا اذا كانت المراه غنيه
ومقتدره فلماذا لا
يفندم دي مش مساواه خالص دي عزه نفس
المنحافظ على عزه نفس المراه
في العمل وسوف الحقوق السياسيه ومتوا
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه في عمل مشاريع في في
تمكين اقتصادي في تمكين اجتماعي لكن ان
انا اتساوي ان انا اروح اخبط على الباب
واطلب ايد شاب انا ملهاش على بنتي تقبلها
وانت رجل ريفي او صعيدي من العياط يا
مولانا ان بنتك تروح تتقدم لشاب وتقول له
انا عايزه اخطب
ابنكم طب نظره الاهل الراجل للبنت ايه
يعني متخيل حضرتك نظره اهل الراجل هتكون
البنت دي ايه طبعا نظره دوينيه اسال البنت
دي ملهاش رابط ما لهاش حاكم ما لهاش اهل
يحكموها اكيد ما حدش يتقدم لها اكيد دي
ملهاش ما عندهاش كرامه ما عندهاش عزه نفس
وحضرتك عارف ان احنا مجتمع شرقي العرف
بيحكموا اكثر من الدين فما ينفعش ان انا
اقلل من قيمه المراه بقصه المساواه
للمساواه ما جتش على الحته لا يا عم احنا
مش احنا الحته دي مش عاوزانا لا احنا
بنساوي في كل حاجه عايزين نحو السياسيه
والاجتماعيه والاقتصاديه وكل شيء الا ان
البنت تروح تهب نفسها لشاب وتقول له انا
عايزاك لان ده بينقص من كرامتها
من كل الضمانات اللي الشرع بيضمن لها
واحنا نشكر جزيل الشكر استاذ الشريعه
الاسلاميه بجامعه الازهر الدكتور احمد
كريمه ونشكر المحاميه والخبيره في شؤون
المراه اشجان البخاري شكرا دكتور شكرا سيد
اشجان شكرا لكما